bonsoir à toutes et à tous et merci de
nous rejoindre sur tv fil 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés la
question du soir les multiplexes
vont-ils définitivement faire
disparaître les cinémas de proximité
vous pouvez réagir participer poser
toutes vos questions à nos invités en
tapant hashtag 7,8 société maurepas
plaisir coignières versailles le chesnay
vélizy on ne compte plus le nombre de
projet de multiplexe dans les environs
comment et qui décide de l'implantation
de ces mastodontes du cinéma les
multiplexes vont-ils significativement
baisser la fréquentation des petits
cinémas et menace-t-il à long terme leur
existence y at il une vision
intercommunale sur cette thématique pour
répondre à ces questions
deux invités autour de la table luc
beaucamp d'abord qui est directeur du
ciné 7 à elancourt depuis 1993 françois
conçoit tristan guillot adjoint au maire
de maurepas délégué à l'environnement au
développement durable et à l'urbanisme
bon alors un projet de multiplex de huit
salles ont obtenu l'aval de la
commission nationale de l'aménagement
commercial le 17 avril dernier et donc
le multiplex de maurepas devrait voir le
jour d'ici fin 2016
dans le village des loisirs retoqué
plusieurs fois surtout sous l'ancienne
mandature le projet voit finalement jour
crise sont bio je pense que c'est un
soulagement pour la ville nous nous en
sommes ravis puisque ce cinéma est pour
nous une forme de locomotive à venir la
zone d'animation paris ouest avait été
prévu justement avec ce cinéma et on
constate en son absence et bien tous les
commerces y sont installés là les les
aires de jeu enfin j'avais ya toute une
tout un panel d'activités qui sont qui
sont présentes et on sent quand même
qu'ils ont du mal à survivre donc c'est
pour ça que nous sommes ravis d'avoir
obtenu cet agrément de
de la commission nationale pour qu'enfin
on puisse avoir ce cinéma avec vos corps
alors moi je rappellerai je suis
absolument pas d'accord
guillaume et tout le monde j'imagine
bien j'imagine
moi je voulais rappeler un petit peu
simplement l'historique de cette de
cette affaire puisque comme vous venez
de le dire vous avez obtenu
l'autorisation à la dernière que naquit
puisque maintenant il faut rajouter un i
cinéma cinémas commission d'aménagement
cinéma est donc là on a gagné si je puis
dire c'est pas une guerre non plus enfin
on a gagné quatre fois de suite et cette
décision de la de l'avant dernière on va
dire c'est assez
y a été cassée pour un vice de forme
puisqu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'éléments dont un an principalement qui
avait été pris en compte dans la
précédente discussions des décisions
pardon qui n'existait plus depuis 2008
donc c'est pour ça que vous avez obtenu
leur passage de ce dossier récemment au
mois d'avril donc à paris nous dire que
les multiplexes de maurepas va se faire
sur une petite erreur administrateurs en
est exactement c'est à dire que c'est ce
vice de forme qui permet cette décision
là et cette décision là elle a été aussi
pris part les hauts fonctionnaires qui
siègera pas que ce sont des haut
fonctionnaires qui siège dans ces
menaces et y
parce que ils ont considéré que la
décision positive qui l avait été donné
au multiplexe de plaisir précédemment
n'ait été comment dirais-je sans objet
maintenant puisque les délais impartis
pour réaliser le projet avait été passée
alors que nous savons pertinemment bien
que la ville de plaisir veut son
multiplexe et qui à mon avis elle leur a
donc enfreint un de plus pour rejoindre
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
nombre de salles présent sur le bassin
de population
nous avons eu beau laurent mazauric
président la sem signer cette moi même
et le secrétaire général de
l'association des français des cinémas
d'art et d'essai expliquer à ces
personnes fortuno râble que nous n'ayons
pas reçu à sa cause voilà on a demandé à
être auditionné que nous n'étions pas
sur le même bassin de population et
l'encours maurepas qui historiquement on
est d'accord je constate qu un seul et
même bassin de population depuis 40 ans
plaisir les clés en étant un autre ils
n'ont pas tenu compte de nos arguments
et ils ont appliqué un certain nombre de
ratios gilles
c'est à dire nombre de salons
d'habitants boom autorisation pour
maurepas donc si je puis dire vous êtes
passé à mon avis parce que les quatre
décisions précédentes
peut-être que j'en oublie ou je rajoute
une je ne sais plus c'est un long sujet
un nombre des bas ça fait longtemps
on se bat nous contre ce projet ne
serait pas passé puisqu'elle avait été
refusée quatre fois de suite ce que ce
que je peux dire c'est que nous sommes
passés donc en commission nationale et
que au vu de la prestation qui a pu
fermer notre mère et puis moi même qui
défendront le dossier comme vous parliez
des des hauts fonctionnaires qui
justement siège à cette commission
ils n'ont pas manqué de nous questionner
j'irai à ses manières assez intensive
tout comme ils ont commencé de
questionner monsieur fonds est géré au
terme de cette discussion ils sont bien
rendu compte que la motivation de la
communauté là que l'intérêt des
habitants et était là enfin je dirais
que tout était réuni pour pouvoir
l'accueillir ce cinéma parce que
l'emplacement était prévu les accès sont
prévues tout est en place
en tant qu adjoint à l'urbanisme j'ai pu
qu'un permis à signer alors
expliquez-moi pourquoi je le disais
précédemment la décision précédente
était négatif et pourquoi elle est
devenue positive aujourd'hui au vu des
arguments qui sont présentés on retire
simplement le fait qu'effectivement il y
avait eu une erreur dans la décision
précédente
parce qu'ils ont tenu compte de la
diversité des équipements et maintenant
cette cet argument là n'est plus pris en
compte donc vice de forme procédure
casse et on repart en cnac
mais pourquoi la décision est elle
aujourd'hui souhaitable positive alors
qu'elle était quatre fois par négative
auparavant
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que même
certains élus favorables la municipalité
présidente donc des gens de gauche sont
opposés au projet donc c'est peut-être
là aussi un des paramètres
ils n'ont pas senti je pense le
l'engouement que nous avons présentés
l'engouement nous avons pour justement
réussir cette cette salle de ce
multiplexe au niveau de 2
de la ville de mortain je crois savoir
cher monsieur que pour avoir assisté à
toutes ces commissions
on en a est auditionné le précédent
maire de ne mord pas et je ne ferai pas
l'injure en disant ça était extrêmement
favorable à ce projet à binche tout tout
oui donc je ne vois pas bien ce qui a
changé
il l'était vous l'êtes oui mais mais
mais la décision change
voilà j'ai du mal à comprendre
personnellement on va continuer la
discussion je vous propose d'écouter
monsieur garcia justement andré goerig
héritié le maire les républicains de
maurepas qui insiste sur le fait que
cette implantation est vital pour mort
par une écoute je défendrai évidemment
le cinéma ne mord pas parce que la
survie du village loisirs en dépend
cela va créer des emplois la décision de
la commission nationale est très clair
nous avons 4 % de croissance de la
population depuis 2000 1999 nous avons
un bassin de vie qui draine très peu en
tout cas
cette dimension culturelle de cinéma
dans ce secteur donc c'est vraiment
drainer le sud yvelines
on en a besoin pour la vitalité du
bassin de vie mais aussi pour la
vitalité de mort pas son dynamisme
on en a besoin à maurepas d'autant plus
que la commission nationale a jugé bon
de dire aussi qu'il ya une
complémentarité entre le ciné 7 et le
futur cinéma ne mord pas alors avant de
revenir à cette complémentarité parce
que je vous ai vu sourire lui beaucamp
sur cette supposée complémentarité entre
le futur multiplexe de maurepas et le et
de signer cette d'elancourt christian
guillot est ce que le permis de conduire
le permis de conduire le permis de
construire par don a été déposée fin
manquera encore alors les travaux
commencent quand dès l'instant que nous
aurons gérer le dépôt du permis de
construire il faut considérer qu'un
délai d'instruction de trois mois nous
semble raisonnable et au terme de ces
trois mois bien évidemment les
pelleteuses seront sur le terrain
mais pour en revenir sur la qualité de
ce multiplex c'est un multiplex qui va
s'intégrer parfaitement dans le cadre de
ceux du secteur très boisé enfin tirer
quelque chose de très naturel
l'agrément tout est en bois je ne vois
pas les voitures les voitures sont
garées en dessous il ya un excédent de 2
places de parking donc qu'on ne créera
pas de nuisances alentours des places de
parking pour handicapés ont été prévus
pareil de beaucoup je crois que ce soit
de l'ordre de 50 ou quelque chose comme
ça non mais attendez on est très
largement au dessus de l'obligation et
il en est même au niveau des places
prévues pour les handicapés dans les
salles si vous voulez c'est chaque salle
aura des places il y aura pas tout une
j'avais pas toute une mécanique à faire
pour pouvoir installer quelqu'un qui est
limité dans ses déplacements il pourra
venir sans aucun problème je s'installer
que chez nous se régale voir maintenant
de toute façon dont on compare les
réactions à
on ne mord pas eh bien écoutez moi je
suis très zen très étonné pour en avoir
parlé avec lui
précédemment alors qu'il était dans
l'opposition il me semblait qu'il
n'était pas pour ce projet mais enfin je
respecte sa parole j'entends ce qu'il me
dit moi je pense et je maintiens que ce
projet a été refusé à quatre reprises
que c'est un projet qui est comment
dirais-je
comme vous venez de le dire d'ailleurs
finalement opportuniste c'est que ce
n'est pas un projet nécessaire pour le
pour les bordjiens et les élans courtois
vous des employés vont pas être réparés
on va pas là bas c'est l'argument facile
c'est à dire que effectivement alors on
sait qu'aujourd'hui un cinéma c'est tout
numériser etc etc
il ya plus de projectionniste en cabine
il ya plus de montage et plus de
démontage de films etc
donc les équipes se réduisent ou alors
elles sont maintenues combien d'emplois
devraient être créés dans ce multiplex
je n'en sais rien je ne connaissais pas
les engagements de monsieur font là
dessus de 15 emplois créés combien
d'emplois risque style de disparaître
sur les salles de proximité que je
défends depuis 20 ans et je continuerai
à défendre ça s'est jamais pris en
compte on n'en parle pas quel va être
l'impact de cette nouvelle implantation
et après je dirais deux mots de
coignières parce que je pense qu'on peut
pas parvenir à codognan april sans
parler de coignières on aime viendra
après quel va être l'impact de cette
nouvelle implantation puisqu'il s'agit
on a tous bien compris de sauver un
village des loisirs qui fonctionne pas
bien effectivement on a pu constater
mais peut-être je ne suis pas comment je
fais pas de politique peut-être ne
fallait-il pas le faire tout simplement
ce village des loisirs bon même si je
regrette pour les gens qui ont investi
dans ces espaces qui n'en soit pas
satisfait autant que faire se peut
aujourd'hui
mais quel va être l'impact sur la ville
de centre-ville moi je rappelle quand
même ça fait longtemps que je travaille
sur les longs courts 1993 comme tu leur
as tout à l'heure mais
moi j'ai le sentiment mais peut-être que
je peux me tromper mais c'est aussi ce
que les gens nous disent aussi 17 ont
fait signer une pétition actuellement on
va l'étendre l'enseigné va l'étendre
parce qu'on est à plus que ça on va
l'étendre parce qu'on va aussi mobiliser
les gens contre coignières c'est pas de
raisons je veux dire on mène pas un
combat uniquement centré sur maurepas
même si on est d'accord c'est
probablement symbolique non on verra
bien si vous voulez de ce qui se passe
c'est que au jour d'aujourd'hui
un père de famille qui veut organiser
une soirée maurepas sienne se faire un
resto faire un bowling faire un cinéma
c'est pas possible
en tant que père de famille moi je
n'étais vraiment pas rassuré de voir mes
enfants partir sur la route le soir
revenir partir à saint quentin
c est quand pourquoi il n'allait pas
aussi les sept d'élan voilà donc
monsieur c'est peut-être aussi parce que
sur place il y avait des désagréments
des choses des jeux enfin qu'il y avait
un peu une structure j pat d'eph acide
est identique
voilà être avertis avaient déteint tout
un ensemble tout un cadre qui qui a
plutôt tendance à attirer les jeunes et
nous nous sommes vraiment des élus de
terrain on était encore sur la la la
fois qu'on appelait la foire au troc
dans le temps maintenant c'est un vide
greniers les gens n'ont pas cessé de
nous parler ils l'attendent et pour les
raisons que que j'évoque si vous voulez
moi je suis sûrement repas depuis 1968
j'ai jamais plus passer une une soirée
mort pas y est né et je trouve que c'est
un petit peu un petit peu dommage
alors justement revenir luc guilbault
quant aux chiffres
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres à nous
donner sur l'impact que il dit voeckler
de l'implantation d'un multiplexe par
rapport au ciné cette des lampes au bon
on a deux exemples gaumont à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc à
montigny en 95 qui avait cinq salles
c'est ma mémoire à six salles pardon et
puis en 2004 justement à l'implantation
de l'ugc alors ça dépend des endroits ça
il faut être très très clair là dessus
très honnête là dessus ça dépend des
endroits
ce que je peux dire moi c'est qu'au
niveau national 60 % des entrées
réalisées dans l'es6 débat en français
sont réalisés dans un peu plus de 20%
des équipements qui sont des multiplexes
c'était 50 % 2
on va mettre ça continue à progresser
donc le multiplex quand il s'installe
effectivement il crée un nouveau public
aussi c'est ce qu'on nous a expliqué
quand il est arrivé
c'est vrai on va dire que messager vu
une certaine pâte manière c'est vrai
mais grignotent aussi de façon comment
dirais-je pernicieuse pernicieuse merci
beaucoup de façon pernicieuse ce qui
existe déjà et pour être clair sur elle
en cours sur le grenier à sel mais je
veux parler à leur place mais peut-être
as-tu des chiffres justement 26 ans
vainqueur chez les chiffres voilà alors
justement vont avoir un petit graphique
avec les chiffres du grenier à sel
puisque dès l'arrivée en 95 de gaumont
et bien ils perdent 24% en 95 dès
l'arrivée de comment et puis en 2004
avec l'arrivée du gc donc skywest 16
salles ils perdent 16%
donc c'est assez significatif ça fait 40
% nous on a perdu 20% alors peut-être
qu'on a perdu un petit peu moins parce
qu'on a une capacité à résister au
niveau de la programmation mais tout ça
c'est important
l'accès aux films vrai qu'on arrive à en
parler dans ce débat parce que c'est
kapisa à six mois ce que je voulais dire
excusez moi je termine ce que je voulais
juste dire c'est que moi j'ai le
sentiment à vous nous dites que les
morts patients attendent l'heure si leur
multiplex moi j'ai le sentiment inverse
c'est à dire que quand ça je peux me
tromper que depuis quarante ans que nous
vivons existe elancourt maurepas qui
sont commencés extrêmement liés en
termes d'habitat de population de
densité moi je sors du ciné cette gelée
dit m puis à maurepas je refais trois
mètres dans l'autre sens je sais que tu
as locaux renvoyait etc
et j'ai l'impression que ça arrive il a
presque un briquet voilages et la mesure
j'ai totalement j'ai l'impression que ça
fait 40 ans que les mots repas indien
viennent au ciné cette sans se poser la
question de savoir si les sept îles et
sur mort poche il encourt y viennent
dans leur cinéma ociné set et je veux
pas parler de quête d'un sujet
douloureux en ce moment qui est la
piscine mais pour pour prendre cet
exemple là j'ai aussi l'impression que
ça fait 40 ans que les allemands
courtois volée qui ne mord pas en lisant
ses notes piscine donc je ne comprends
pas au regard de ces arguments là et
aussi au regard du fait que je rappelle
que la ville de maurepas et actionnaires
du 6 et 7 actionnaires dont je ne
comprends pas
oui je ne comprends pas cette position
si ce n'est les arguments on va dire
économique que vous donnez que je peux
entendre parfaitement je comprends ce
que j'ai dit justement dans les
sécrétions guillot répondent beaucoup
reposé une bonne question puisque
maurepas est actionnaire à ce qu'il ne
se tire pas une balle dans le pied on
n'est pas du tout la concurrence
parce que si vous voulez ou au delà du
cinéma traditionnel
nous avons convenu avec monsieur fonds
qui auraient une salle imax
c'est à dire tateurs ce c'est du cinéma
en grande dimension enfin je dirais on
est vraiment noyé dans le on est dans le
décor si vous voulez et donc ça c'est
très important parce que dirait au delà
de la clientèle qui il y a autour de
maurepas elancourt il ya des gens qui
vont à paris dans des salles imac parce
qu'ils veulent vivre ce type de de
présentation enfin bon je dirais c'est
très intéressant et avec toutes les
modifications qui vont être apportées au
niveau de circulation entre la zone
commerciale et la gare de la verrière
puisque prochainement tout ça ça sera en
plateau et en trois minutes en voiture
ou en bus
on sera dû signer à la gare comprenez
bien qu'il ya des gens qui viendront
d'un petit peu partout et en même temps
notre bassin de de clientèle si je peux
dire ainsi pour le cinéma ne se contente
pas seulement à maurepas ils encourent
c'est tous les gens que l'ardeur qui
sont qui vont vers dreux donc toute la
campagne ces personnes là ça va les
intéresser d'avoir 10 ou 15 km de moins
fait pour venez sur ce thème et sur
cette baisse de fréquentation alors
qu'on vient vous allez les chiffres et
le grenier assez à la trappe est
également mal j'ai pas de chiffres à
vous donner j'ai simplement de des
bonnes intentions dont je veux faire
part à monsieur c'est que monsieur fonds
est tout à fait d'accord avec nous pour
qu'on puisse voir ensemble géré les
programmations
on ne veut surtout pas tué
le ciné 7 le ciné 7 il faut que les deux
les deux structures soient
complémentaires soit gagnant-gagnant
justement vous parlez de structures
complémentaires et bien il y en a une
troisième qui arrive dans le jeu puisque
vendredi dernier la commission
départementale d'aménagement commercial
a validé le dossier d'un multiplexe de
11 salles à coignières on écoute la
réaction de jean-pierre sevestre donc le
maire de coignières qui émet des
réserves sur la viabilité des deux
multiplexes de cinéma effectivement
économiquement c'est très difficile
ce sera très difficile effectivement il
faut absolument qu'il y ait quand même
une entente cinématographique sur le
secteur pour arriver à quelque chose qui
soit raisonnable
bien sûr nous avons de deux projets qui
ont obtenu la corde d'aménagement
cinématographique et dames et
d'aménagement commercial il n'y a que le
projet de coignières qui a obtenu cet
aménagement commercial donc nous n'avons
pas seulement nous le cinéma nous avons
également autour
si vous voulez un lieu d'animation avec
les restaurants et les moyennes surfaces
ou magasins nous sommes encore qu'à la
co lendemain de effectivement des cdac
favorable donc il est probable que de
deux projets livrés difficilement sur le
sur le sur la zone d'activités sur notre
zone de chalandise oui alors justement
christophe lui à ce que jean pierre
sauvestre et gregory k restiez se sont
rencontrés et comment ils vont réussir à
résoudre ce casse-tête
déjà il faut voir quand même qu'on a des
administrations qui sont pas un non sens
prêt parce que donner un accord pour
deux multiplexes 1 km l'un de l'autre de
mieux faire je dirais pourquoi parler
d'un fonctionnaire ce n'est pas sur le
terrain mais pas tous sans rentrer dans
le combat des fonctionnaires la cdac les
jeunes la mère de coignières avenir
justement sur la zone dans laquelle nous
souhaitons et nous allons installer le
cinéma de maurepas on n'est pas
contrairement à eux pour l'instant au
milieu de nulle part
nous avons tout un centre commercial qui
existe nous avons des activités qui
existent en masse et voix hier également
non à à cet endroit là il ya rien
attention que des entrepôts donc à rien
de prévu
apparemment il ya d'autres choses qui
sont précis juste face ils sont non non
non ils sont simplement face aux comment
actuellement stockage hnf commerce juste
nommé niveau ils vont mettre des
commerces
après mais au jour d'aujourd'hui cette
implantation se fais comme j'appelle ça
au milieu de nulle part
c'est à dire que vous avez des entrepôts
qu'ils vont être soit réaménagé soit
rasée mais nous actuellement c'est pour
ça je le dis bien tout existe autour il
la pièce manquante du puzzle
c'est le cinéma il ya toutes les
activités il ya les voiries les
spectacles les restaurants et les
grandes surfaces yeux en évoquant
comment on peut accepter
comment de commissions différentes
certes la classe i et la cdac comme
elles peuvent accepter a même pas je ne
sais pas combien de mes trios entre
coignières est mort pas mais bon il va
accepter qu'ils 2 et projet de
multiplexe parce que vous avez été
consultés d'heure sur ce
on a été pour être tout à fait clair là
dessus on a été prévenu de cette de
cette réunion qui a eu lieu si ma
mémoire est bonne jeudi dernier une
journée et demie avant les délais
nécessaires pour pouvoir demander à être
auditionnée en préfecture on a décidé de
pas y aller
puisque de toute façon on est
actuellement en train de s'interroger
sur le fait qu'on dépose ou pas un
recours contre le projet de maurepas on
va en déposer un je pense contre le
projet de coignières trophées ramenés au
cias ils ont été posées contre poignée
j'imagine on est cohérent donc j'imagine
que maurepas avait déposé un recours
contre coignières que coignard va
déposer un recours contre maurepas enfin
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on en est à peu
près là donc voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement vous disiez tout à
l'heure vision intercommunale va la
preuve en est qu'ils aient d'annaba qui
serait facilement si nous étions dans
une interview à reuters que ce problème
ne se serait pas posée si nous avions
été dans une terre couvre 26
l'intercours à passer à 12 avec notre
aide dans les parcs on va se faire à
partir du mois de janvier et est bien
évidemment quand on parle de projet de
cette ampleur c'est une discussion une
décision collégiale qui se ferait alors
que là chacun façon bon et il dirait on
nous on n'en veut pas on n'en veut pas
contenir de toute façon il était tiré
sage pour eux deux près d'avoir un
projet en réserve à sortir parce qu' il
n'était pas du tout évident que la
commune de maurepas arrive enfin à voir
sur scène voilà justement voulu que ces
deux projets triste qui se télescopent
mais j'irai le maire de maurepas le
maire de coignières agir et aucune
raison qu'on qu'on se fout qu'on fasse
des recours dirai à mon sens par la
discussion tout comme avec vous pour
votre votre activité actuelle par la
discussion on est des adultes on est
justement on va écouter gregorio
monsieur guillon va écouter grégory leca
restiez qui nous parle de l'avenir du
ciné 7 pour lui vous n'avez pas à vous
en faire
luc bouron puisqu'il y aurait un
engagement notamment avec cinémovida on
écoute grégory guéri astier quand saint
quentin à développer le sien avec que
j'ai csss salle
ça n'a pas de tuer pour autant le ciné
set puisqu'il ya une troisième salle qui
qui étaient réalisés donc je pense qu'il
ya une complémentarité
d'autant plus que l'opérateur cinémovida
s'est engagé par écrit à avoir un accord
avec le ciné 7 pour que justement cette
complémentarité se fasse dans le temps
au travers de chèques que cinéma au
travers d'une programmation en version
originale laisser au ciné cette au
travers d'activités pour les scolaires
laissait également au ciné cette voie là
il s'est engagé vraiment avec des
engagements forts pour permettre
justement au ciné cette de continuer
c'est un cinéma de quartier qui ne
draine pas la même clientèle
alors justement ligue beau quand vous
avez reçu un courrier où est-ce qu'ils
avaient rencontré jacques fondre sur ce
que dit grégory caret score une fois
soyons très clairs sur ce que dit
monsieur le maire de maurepas je connais
jacques fond je les rencontrais je les
rencontrais récemment et on a discuté
effectivement on s'est vus on s'est vus
assez rapidement mais on a discuté
effectivement d'un éventuel accord de
programmation mais c'était moi qui lui
posait des questions alors déjà que font
ces l'exploitant du projet de m je
n'étais absolument pas au courant de cet
accord de programmation et j'ai appris
lors de la commission nationale à
laquelle nous avons assisté tous les
deux puisque c'est un des membres qui
siégeaient qui m'a sorti nous a sorti un
papier aux anges est ici un accord
déposée par monsieur fonds cnc de
programmation cet arrêt sera très bien
où est-il je ne mets pas reçus gelé pas
lu je n'ai pas vu c'est la stricte
vérité
premièrement deuxièmement quand monsieur
gary astier dit monsieur fonds est prêt
à laisser aussi 17 la programmation
scolaire très bien ça fait 20 ans qu'on
fait ce travail là notamment avec la
grande majorité des écoles de bourg par
qui sont formidables estimé que les
filmer mais voilà mais c'est pas ça qui
fait vivre une entreprise un cd place à
2 euros est et restera la vo c'est
formidable moi j'adore le film en vo
mais on sait bien que c'est un petit peu
plus difficile quand même que la vf
voilà donc ce qu'on oublie complètement
de dire
je voudrais de conclure en même temps je
conclue rapidement dans cette dans ce
dossier là et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
disaient aussi monsieur le maire de
coignières que je viens d'entendre c'est
que on parle là du multiplexe de
maurepas du multiplexe de coignières
mais on parle pas du cinéma de proximité
on parle pas du ciné 7
on nous on essaie de nous vendre un
pseudo accord qui de toute façon même si
on n'y arrivait et je ne dis pas qu'on
va pas essayer d'y arriver si c'est
possible
ce sera très compliqué et ça il faut que
vous sachiez ça très compliquée à mettre
en oeuvre dans la façon dont sera
respectée terminale s il ne le sera s'il
n'est pas respecté
moi je vais passer ma vie à monter au
médiateur du cinéma pour nous respect de
l'accord je vais faire merci merci merci
le progrès on arrive déjà au terme de
l'émission merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'était passionnant
n'hésitez pas à réagir sur twitter en
tapant hashtag 7,8 société on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine bonne
soirée à tous